on passe maintenant à riz à la mairie
est là
alors elle a réagi un événement qui a
fait le buzz en france et qui a traversé
des frontières c'est bien sur ce
sauvetage d'un enfant par mamoudou
gassama on a reçu d'ailleurs d'entente
et pmp et elle s'était émue de cet acte
héroïque regarder films et par les
passants son acte de bravoure
spectaculaire a été visionnée des
millions de fois sur les réseaux sociaux
l'exploit de mamoudou gassama a traversé
les frontières la réception à l'elysée
aussi et il y en a une qui est très
heureux de cette belle histoire c'est
rihanna oui oui rihanna sur le compte
instagram d' emmanuel macron elle a
posté ce commentaire
ce rapide après avoir été reçus l'an
dernier à l'elysée elle a recroisé le
couple présidentiel à dakar et ça colle
riri continue son idylle avec les mâcon
trop la classe non alors autant madame
kardashian c'est donald trump ça ne fait
pas du tout pour moi je les dis mais là
se trouve que rihanna une vraie
conscience sociale à s'intéresse à ce
qui se passe en france
moi j'adore je trouve qu'elle prend
position sur des sujets bravo rihanna
[Musique]
et voici je me forge par les images
c'est pas sûr